the nfc east at one time was stocked top
to bottom with great teams now it's
really hard to figure out who the best
team is in that division the eagles won
the super bowl just a season ago the
cowboys rebounded last year and won the
division washington the giants just kind
of hanging around if you're watching on
nbcsn you can see the moves that have
been made and most recently the cowboys
pick up defensive end robert quinn the
eagles pick up running back jordan
howard
and i'd say it's between those two teams
big cat is the best in the nfc east and
look who knows how the cowboys are going
to come together or not come together
they look like the best team on paper
but last year the eagles came on so
strong late in the year if they can keep
carson wentz healthy all season long i
think they are a threat not just to win
that division but maybe to win the
conference
yeah i mean this is actually easy for me
because you throw out the redskins you
throw out the giants between the cowboys
and the eagles
the cowboys won the nfc east last year
so what does history tell us the eagles
have to win it next year because there
has not been a repeat winner since 2004
ready for this mike
since 2004 eagles giants eagles cowboys
giants cowboys eagles giants redskins
eagles cowboys redskins cowboys eagles
cowboys
well there you go you've done your
research that's good
yeah uh no no nobody's won it twice in a
row since 2004. that's what i'll say
back to you
look
they they are so
competitive among themselves and they
beat the hell out of each other and you
never know how those home and home games
are going to go and one year it's the
giants own the cowboys the next year
it's the cowboys owned washington then
the eagles on washington and how those
games work out really goes a long way
toward determining who ends up on top in
that division and every year it works
out a different way but the cowboys feel
like the team and to have and that's
that's bad for them every year they feel
like the team that's going to be good is
the year they're not good it's the year
when we don't know what to expect from
the cowboys that they find a way to put
it all together i take the eagles very
very seriously i think this jordan
howard move for them fills a huge need i
i worry about the weapons for carson
wentz do they have enough on the outside
do they have i mean desean jackson can
he still run at some point he's not
going to be able to do what he used to
do if he can stretch the field that's a
huge plus but when staying healthy is
the number one concern if he stays
healthy wire to wire i think the eagles
win that division easily
i mean the the sean jackson question yes
he can still run because you saw it last
year with tampa bucks and that is
well that's fine but he did that's a
great addition for them they jordan
howard's a great addition they added uh
you know cendejo malik jackson here's
what it comes down to though mike if you
had to ask yourself and you had to you
know put your life on the line who do
you trust in this in this threesome i'm
about to say do you trust carson wentz
doug peterson howie roseman or do you
trust dak prescott jason garrett jerry
jones i know the answer for me it's
easily the eagles and the other thing
with the eagles last year obviously they
win the super bowl first time in
franchise history there was clearly
going to be a period of time where it
was adjusting they didn't maybe play up
to their competition they came on strong
at the end of the year carson wentz was
never really healthy it felt like for
the entire year so hopefully he comes
back fully healthy but i think that
eagles team has so much talent they've
been through it they've won the big
games they're now a year removed from
all that success maybe resting on their
laurels a little bit because that's just
human nature i think the eagles will
very easily easily win the nfc east next
year
i just worry about carson wentz staying
healthy they can't unwire this guy he
goes out there he plays hard he plays
recklessly and will he figure out that
connection between the way he plays and
the fact that he's been injured each of
the last two decembers they don't have
nick foles to come in and save the bacon
this year what will nate sutfelt do they
supposedly really like him but
who knows will they entrust him with
that job or will they try to find
someone else to be the primary backup to
carson wentz in the event he gets hurt
again at some point they can't be
surprised about him getting injured and
at some point they have to realize if
you're not available i say this all the
time franchise quarterback has to be
available to the franchise you can't be
missing large chunks of every season and
be one of the best quarterbacks in the
nfl big cat but i think they're going to
make that a priority that carson wentz
has to change his game maybe stay in the
pocket a little more take less risks
because he can't get injured every year
and once you get injured two years in a
row that's a wake-up call for carson
wentz so i think he'll be fine
has anyone ever really made that change
i think few have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports